WE WILL KEEP WATCHING.
NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
CONGRESSWOMAN
NICOLE MALLIOTAKIS, THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
FOX NEWS HAS NOW CONFIRMED THAT
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS AND
EL HUNTER HAYEK MAY ARCUS WILL
VISIT THE U.S.-MEXICO BORDER AND
THIS WILL BE JUST DAYS BEFORE
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
AND REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS ARE
PLANNING TO VISIT THE BORDER.
IT HAS BEEN 91 DAYS SINCE
PRESIDENT BIDEN NAMED HARRIS AS
THE BORDERS ARE.
REPUBLICANS HAVE HEAVILY
CRITICIZED HER FOR NOT VISITING
THE PORTER SINCE THEN, THOUGH
SHE HAS MADE TRIPS TO OTHER
PLACES LIKE GUATEMALA IF YOU’RE
JOINING IS NOW,
SENATOR TED CRUZ.
IT WAS HER HAND FOR US SHE HAD
TO GET THERE BEFORE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> OF COURSE IT WAS.
94 DAYS AGO, SHE WAS NAMED AS
BORDERS ARE, AND SHE
DEMONSTRATED STRONG LEADERSHIP
BY DOING NOT DAMN THING, BY
DOING EVERYTHING SHE COULD TO
HIDE FROM THE CRISIS.
FRANKLY, THAT IS THE SAME THING
JOE BIDEN IS DOING.
SHE IS EMULATING HIM AND HIDING
FROM THE CRISIS, SO SUDDENLY
THEY REALIZED, CRAP, WE’VE GOT
TO DO SOMETHING.
EL PASO IS A LOVELY CITY.
BEAUTIFUL PLACE IN TEXAS.
IT IS NOT ALSO -- DOES NOT
HAPPEN TO BE THE LOCUST OF THE
CRISIS.
THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY ISN’T --
AND FOR FOLKS WHO ARE NOT FROM
TEXAS, LET ME GIVE YOU A SENSE.
IT IS ON THE WESTERN TIP OF
TEXAS.
THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY IS ON THE
SOUTHERN TIP.
IT IS 800 MILES AWAY.
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF JUST HOW
FAR THEY ARE, CHICAGO, ILLINOIS,
IS CLOSER TO WASHINGTON, D.C.,
THEN EL PASO IS TO THERE.
SO SHE IS GOING WHERE THE HEIGHT
OF THE PROBLEM ISN’T.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT KAMALA
NEEDS TO DO.
THE KAMALA, YOU NEED TO GO TO
THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY.
YOU NEED TO GO TO THE FACILITY,
THE TENT CITY YOUR
ADMINISTRATION HAS BUILT THAT IS
MASSIVELY OVERCAPACITY THAT HAS
KIDS IN CAGES.
YOU NEED TO LOOK AT THE CHILDREN
IN CAGES THAT YOU AND JOE BIDEN
PUT THEIR AND I THAT IS
ENDANGERING THEIR SAFETY,
SUBJECTING THEM TO ABUSE AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT, AND THERE IS A
REASON, JOHN, SHE IS NOT GOING
THERE.
IT’S NOT GOING TO THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY, BECAUSE SHE DOES NOT
WANT THE CAMERAS TO SEE THE
JOE BIDEN CAGES WITH KIDS IN
CAGES.
>> John: THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO SAY THAT SHE DID NOT
WANT TO HAVE THAT PHOTOGRAPH OR
VIDEO TO BE REPLAYED AGAIN AND
AGAIN, BUT IN ALL FAIRNESS, THE
EL PASO SECTOR IS WHERE THE
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER, KEVIN
McCARTHY, AND A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS WENT.
THEY ALSO WENT TO ARIZONA.
SORRY, THE NEW MEXICO SECTORS AS
WELL, SO REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
THERE ALL THE WALLS OF.
>> SHORT.
I HAVE BEEN TO EL PASO MANY,
MANY TIMES.
IT IS A WONDERFUL COMMUNITY.
IT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
COMMUNITY, AND THERE ARE
CERTAINLY REAL PROBLEMS WITH
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IN EL PASO,
BUT THERE IS A REASON SHE
DOESN’T WANT THE TV CAMERAS TO
SHOW HUNDREDS UPON HUNDREDS AND
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN LYING SIDE-BY-SIDE BY
SIDE.
YOU REMEMBER A COUPLE OF MONTHS
AGO, WHEN I TOOK 19 SENATORS
DOWN TO THE BORDER, AND WE WENT
DOWN TO YOU THAT FACILITY.
IT WAS BUILT TO HOLD A THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
THE DAY WE WERE THERE, THERE
WERE OVER 4,200 PEOPLE PACKED IN
THAT FACILITY WITH A 10% COVID
POSITIVITY RATE.
KAMALA HARRIS NEEDS TO LOOK IN
THE EYES OF THE CHILDREN WHO ARE
SUFFERING BECAUSE OF JOE BIDEN’S
FAILED IMMIGRATION POLICY, AND
WHEN SHE REALIZES THIS ISN’T
WORKING, THAT IS WHEN THEY NEED
TO AND CATCH AND RELEASE, AND
THEY NEED TO REINSTATE THE
EVERYMAN IN MEXICO INTERNATIONAL
AGREEMENT THAT HAS SOLVED THIS
PROBLEM UNTIL JOE BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS GREETED UP HERE
>> Gillian: CENTER, THIS IS
GILLIAN TURNER ALONG WITH JOHN
HERE IN THE D.C. BUREAU.
I AM CURIOUS, DESPITE EVERYTHING
YOU LAID OUT, THE CRITICISM OF
THE FACT THAT THIS IS COMING
LATE AND SHE IS GOING TO EL PASO
RATHER THAN RIO GRANDE, ARE YOU
HAPPY SHE IS MAKING THIS TRIP?
IT IS SOMETHING YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN CALLING FOR
FOR MONTHS.
SENATOR COTTON JUST TWEETED OUT
REACTION TO THE NEWS.
HE SAID "COMPLETE MISTAKE.
KAMALA HARRIS WILL FIND SOME WAY
TO MAKE THE CRISIS WORSE."
SO NOW IT SOUNDS LIKE SHE IS
FINALLY DOING WHAT YOU GUYS WANT
HER TO DO, BUT THERE IS STILL A
LOT OF UNHAPPINESS.
>> SHORT, I AM HAPPY SHE IS
GOING TO THE BORDER, BUT SHE
DOESN’T HAVE ANY SOLUTIONS.
SHE HAS GOTTEN A LOT OF GRIEF
FOR NOT GOING TO THE BORDER.
ANY RATIONAL PERSON WOULD SAY MY
GOSH, IF YOU ARE NAMED IN CHARGE
OF THE BORDER, GILLIAN, IF THE
PRESIDENT CALLED AND SAID
GILLIAN IS IN CHARGE, I AM
WILLING TO BET WITHIN -- WHAT?
24, 48, MAYBE 72 HOURS, YOU GET
ON A PLANE AND SAY IF I AM IN
CHARGE OF THIS THING, LET ME SEE
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> Gillian: YOU WELL, WE WOULD
HAVE A LOT OF PROBLEMS IF I WAS
TASKED WITH HANDLING THE BORDER
TOMORROW, BUT IT IS NOT JUST
YOUR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES WHO H
BEEN UNHAPPY WITH THIS.
A LOT OF AMERICANS WHO LIVE
ALONG THE BORDER, THEY SAY THAT
THEY NEED HELP.
THEY NEED HER EYES ON THE
GROUND, OR THE PRESIDENT’S EYES
ON THE GROUND TO UNDERSTAND, IN
ADDITION TO THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE UNDERLYING PROBLEMS,
AMERICA’S UNDERLYING PROBLEMS.
SPEAK OUT I THINK THAT IS
EXACTLY RIGHT.
WE ARE SEEING INCREASED DRUGS
AND VIOLENCE.
THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN DISASTER.
IT IS A PUBLIC HEALTH DISASTER,
NATIONAL SECURITY DISASTER, AND
THE THING THAT IS IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND, THIS IS MAN-MADE.
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS COST
OF THIS WHEN THEY REINSTATED THE
FAILED POLICY OF CATCH AND
RELEASE.
REMAIN IN MEXICO WAS AN
INTERNATIONAL AGREEMENT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD NEGOTIATED
WITH MEXICO OR MEXICO AGREED
THAT ANYONE WHO CROSSED
ILLEGALLY INTO MEXICO, THEY
WOULD STAY THERE IN MEXICO WELL
THEY ARE U.S. ASYLUM CASE
PRECEDENT, AND IT ENDED UP
WORKING INCREDIBLY WELL.
LAST YEAR, AND THE YEAR 2020, WE
HAVE THE LOWEST RATE OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND 45 YEARS.
IT WAS INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL.
WHEN JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS
TOUR THAT INTERNATIONAL
AGREEMENT TO SHREDS, WE WENT
FROM THE LOWEST RATE IN 45 YEARS
TO TODAY, THE HIGHEST RATE IN
OVER 20 YEARS.
WE HAVE ALREADY HAD HALF OF A
MILLION PEOPLE COME IN
ILLEGALLY, AND WE ARE ON PACE
FOR MORE THAN 2 MILLION PEOPLE
IN THE FIRST YEAR OF THE BIDEN-
BIDEN-HARRIS ADMINISTRATION.
THEY NEED TO FIX IT.
THE PEOPLE OF TEXAS ARE ON THE
FRONT LINES, PAYING THE PRICE,
AND THE REASON KAMALA WAITED 91
DAYS IS SHE KNEW IF SHE WENT, TV
CAMERAS WOULD COME, AND THEY
WERE DOCUMENTS THAT HUMAN
MISERY, THE CHAOS AND DISASTER
THAT BIDEN AND HARRIS ARE
PRODUCING, AND THEY DON’T HAVE
ANY ANSWERS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
GIVEN THE RADICAL LEFT A PROMISE
THAT THEY WILL NOT ENFORCE THE
LAWS.
THEY WILL NOT SUPPORT PEOPLE.
THEY WILL HAVE OPEN BORDERS, AND
THEY ARE CAUSING THE SUFFERING
RIGHT NOW.
>> John: WE SHOULD POINT OUT
THAT FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP AS
JOSS WHEDON, SAYING "AFTER
MONTHS OF IGNORING THE CRISIS AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER, IT IS GREAT
THAT WE’VE GOT KAMALA HARRIS TO
FINALLY GO AND SEE THE
TREMENDOUS DESTRUCTION AND DEATH
THEY’VE CREATED, DIRECT RESULTS
OF THE BIDEN ENDING MY VERY
TOUGH BUT FAIR BORDER POLICIES.
NOW IT IS BY FAR THE WORST,
GOVERNOR ABBOTT AND I WERE NOT
GOING TO THE BORDER NEXT WEEK,
SHE WOULD HAVE NEVER GONE."
YOU DON’T HAVE ANY EXPECTATION,
DO YOU, THAT THE VICE PRESIDENT
WILL GO VISIT THE EL PASO SECTOR
AND SAY OH, MY GOODNESS, WHAT WE
ARE DOING ISN’T WORKING, WE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
>> NO, I THINK WHAT SHE WILL SAY
IS WE NEED TO TURN THE REVOLVING
DOOR EVEN FASTER.
AS SOON AS WE APPREHEND SOMEONE,
WE NEED TO LET THEM GO EVEN MORE
QUICKLY.
THEY ARE TRYING TO SHIFT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY,
AND IT IS REALLY STUNNING.
YOU GO DOWN TO THE BORDER, AND
YOU SEE THIS CARAVAN OF PEOPLE.
IT IS NOT EVEN THAT WERE TO
PATROL AGENTS ARE APPREHENDING
THEM.
THEY TURN THEMSELVES IN BECAUSE
THE BIDEN-HARRIS ADMINISTRATION
RIGHT NOW IS THE LAST MILE OF
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND HUMAN
SMUGGLING NETWORK.
IF THE CARTELS GET THEM JUST
OVER THE RIVER, AND THEN THEY
FIND THE ADMINISTRATION, THEY
WILL SHIP THEM TO WHEREVER THEY
WANT TO GO, AND KAMALA’S ONLY
SOLUTION TO THAT IS LESS PROCESS
EVEN FASTER, AND THE RESULT IS
TRAGICALLY GOING TO BE EVEN MORE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THE ONLY ANSWER IS TO ENFORCE
THE LAWS AND TO MOVE BACK TO
WHAT WE KNOW WAS WORKING JUST A
FEW MONTHS AGO, THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY, BUT THERE RADICAL
POLITICS WILL NOT LET THEM DO
IT.
>> Gillian: SENATOR, WE KNOW
THAT YOU DISAGREE WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION’S BROADER POLICY
AT LARGE.
WE KNOW THAT YOU’RE NOT HAPPY
WITH THE SITUATION ON THE GROUND
INSIDE OF TEXAS OR THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE BORDER IN MEXICO,
BUT GIVEN THE REALITY AS IT IS
RIGHT NOW TODAY, WHAT IS THE
BEST POSSIBLE MESSAGING YOU CAN
SEE THE VICE PRESIDENT DELIVER
WHEN SHE’S OVER THERE?
IS THAT ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT
SHE SAID LAST MONTH WHEN SHE
TOLD THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE
MIGRANTS TO NOT COME TO THE
U.S., OR IS IT SOMETHING ELSE?
>> THOSE WERE EMPTY WORDS WHEN
SHE SAID THAT IN GUATEMALA.
YOU LOOK AT THE PRESIDENT OF
GUATEMALA, OPENLY POINTED OUT
THAT BIDEN AND HARRIS, THEIR
MESSAGE WAS, ILLEGALLY, THAT
PROBLEMS DOWN MY QUARTERS ARE
OPEN.
THAT’S WHY YOU SEE THEM CROSSING
WEARING JOE BIDEN T-SHIRTS
BECAUSE YOU GET TO CROSS OVER IT
ILLEGALLY, AND THEY ARE CAUSING
THIS, AND LOOK.
THEY THINK IT IS --
>> Gillian: SORRY, IF YOU HAD
THE CHANCE TO ADVISE HER ON WHAT
YOU SAY ON THIS TRIP, WHAT IS
THE MESSAGE HERE?
>> HERE IS ONE, HERE IS SHOULD
SAY.
WE ARE REVERSING THREE DECISIONS
THAT JOE BIDEN AND I MADE IN THE
FIRST WEEK OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
JOE BIDEN HALTED CONSTRUCTION OF
THE BORDER WALL.
WE ARE RESUMING CONSTRUCTION.
JOE BIDEN REINSTATED THE FAILED
POLICY OF CATCH AND RELEASE.
WE ARE ENDING CATCH AND RELEASE,
SO IF YOU GET APPREHENDED, WE
ARE NOT JUST GOING TO LET YOU GO
AND STAY IN AMERICA.
NUMBER THREE, JOE BIDEN END OF
THE REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY.
THAT HAS PROVEN TO BE AN
ENORMOUS MISTAKE.
WE REALIZE IT WAS A MISTAKE, SO
WE ARE REINSTATING THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY, WHICH PRODUCE THE
LOWEST RATE OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
THAT IS WHAT SHE SHOULD SAY.
THE CHANCES THAT SHE WILL SAY
THAT ARE ZERO.
BECAUSE BIDEN AND HARRIS HAVE
HANDED CONTROL OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION AGENDA OVER TO THE
RADICAL LEFT, WHO DON’T WANT THE
LAWS IN FORCE.
THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS.
THEY SUPPORT OPEN BORDERS, AND
UNTIL JOE AND KAMALA ARE WILLING
TO CHANGE THEIR POLICIES, THIS
CHAOS, THIS CRISIS WILL KEEP
GETTING WORSE AND WORSE.
THERE WILL BE MORE VIOLENT, MORE
MURDERS, MARK HERTEL, AND MORE
DRUGS KILLING AMERICANS ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY.
>> John: THERE IS A LOT OF
PRESSURE FROM PROGRESSIVES TO
RESEND IT TITLE 42, WHICH HAS
RESULTED IN 62% OF THE PEOPLE
THAT CROSS THE BORDER EVERY
MONTH, INCLUDING MORE THAN
100,000 IN THE MONTH OF MAY, TO
BE SENT BACK OVER THE BORDER.
IF THIS ADMINISTRATION WERE TO
RESEND TITLE 42, WHAT DO YOU
THINK WOULD HAPPEN?
>> THE PROBLEM WOULD GET EVEN
WORSE.
AT LEAST DURING A PANDEMIC GAVE
YOU THE ABILITY TO EXCLUDE SOME
ADULTS, AND EARLY ON, WITHIN THE
FIRST WEEK, BIDEN AND HARRIS PUT
A BIG EXCEPTION IN TITLE 42 THAT
BASICALLY SAID IF YOU HAVE A KID
WITH YOU, YOU CAN STAY, AND WHAT
WE STARTED SEEING, AND THE
NUMBERS HAVE BEEN EXPLODING, WE
STARTED SEEING SINGLE ADULT
MALES WOULD SHOP WITH A KID, AND
WHEN YOU DNA TEST THE KIDS, A
VERY SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE ARE
NOT RELATED TO THOSE.
THE CARTELS ARE LITERALLY
RENTING KIDS TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, AND THESE KIDS ARE
BEING HORRIBLY ABUSED.
THAT IS THE RESULTS OF
BIDEN-HARRIS’ POLICY’S POLICY.
>> John: THAT IS SOMETHING WE
HAVE COVERED, BUT IT IS 62% OF
ALL OF THE BORDER ENCOUNTERS IN
THE MONTH OF MAY, THERE WAS LIKE
190,000 OF THOSE, WERE SENT BACK
OVER THE BORDER, IF YOU WERE TO
USE RESCIND TITLE 42, DO YOU
EXPECT THAT THERE WOULD BE
TIDAL WAVES OF PEOPLE WHO TRY TO
GET ACROSS THE BORDER?
>> I THINK THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT
BECAUSE THAT TAKES CATCH AND
RELEASE AND PUTS IT ON STEROIDS.
IT MAKES THE POLICY OF THE
BIDEN-HARRIS ADMINISTRATION,
BASICALLY WHOEVER COMES GETS
RELEASED, AND LET ME TELL YOU
HOW BACKWARDS THEIR POLICY IS.
THEY ARE RELEASING HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL ALIENS INTO
THIS COUNTRY, MANY OF THEM
WITHOUT COVID TESTS, OF THEM
WERE FACILITIES WITH COVID IS
ABOUT 10% POSITIVITY.
AT THE SAME TIME, JOE BIDEN JUST
REINSTITUTED THE BAN ON LEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND FOLKS CROSSING
THE PORTS OF ENTRY AND TAXES TO
COME TO TEXAS, TO GO SHOPPING.
PEOPLE ARE COMING ILLEGALLY.
THEY SHUT THAT DOWN.
THEY SAID THAT IS NONESSENTIAL.
I’VE GOT TO SAY THAT IS
BACKWARDS.
THEY OUGHT TO OPEN THOSE PORTS
OF ENTRY TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
AND THEY OUGHT TO STOP RELEASING
AND ENCOURAGING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
THEY GET THAT TOTALLY BACKWARDS.
>> John: THANKS FOR JUMPING IN
ON SHORT NOTICE.
THE BIG NEWS THAT KAMALA HARRIS
AND A ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS, THE
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY,